what
how's it going breasts my name is real
bad and welcome to episode I don't even
know but anyway thank you
first off I want to say thank you bros
so much for 1 million six hundred
thousand subscribers that is an insane
number I realize that a lot of the
success about this channel is a bad you
know you brother being on hey have you
heard of pearpad yeah it's pretty cool
I've got like you should got a patch
that was so stupid
my point is you bros tell each other
bros about this channel and that's
really a big part of why this channel is
so successful so thank you brothers for
doing that I really appreciate it it's
cool like we're still the fastest
growing channel on YouTube this week at
least
but really who [ __ ] cares
now that we are 1,600,000 grows I
thought why not wanna turn this into
something awesome list this is all
everyone is watching this video I want
as part of the bro army let's all get
together and do something awesome so I
thought we'd do a charity fundraise and
it's gonna be for children with cancer
pretty much all you got to do to donate
it's a link in description you can
choose from ten to fifty dollars to
donate and it has many reasons why you
should do that I will go on to those
later I feel extremely lucky to be the
man I am today not only because of you
bros and all the things you do but also
because I'm healthy and it's easy to
take that for granted it is easy to take
again and how lucky you are just being
healthy and there are so many people out
there whose who's not that lucky and I I
think why not why not help them not why
not why not do that there's I don't know
I think it's kind of obvious why you
should help out for this cause like I
said all the money will go to helping
children with cancer it will be donated
to st. Jude's Children's Research
Hospital if you want to read more about
them I'll leave the link in the
description but I I wanted to you know
put myself out there and being ya you
know do what I can to help make you bros
want to donate so anyone donating more
than fifty fifty dollars will receive a
special thank you for letter from me it
will all
to get an email so you can get in
contact with me if that's something
you'd like to do and be part of this
fundraiser and maybe more fundraising
projects in the future so that's what
you'll get from that if you donate over
25 you'll get this thank-you note from
me and I will be doing live streams as
much as I can and all the money that I
earn from the live stream I will donate
to charity what else I will try to
remind everyone of this because it's you
know if you could say like oh if
everyone donates $1
then we'll have $1,600,000 you know
that's not gonna happen that's obvious
but I really need the little health I
can get from all you bros with this so
all you got to do is go to the
description you'll donate through PayPal
uh you'll also get a little donate note
on forums which is awesome so let's bros
let's freakin do this that's all just
you know show them how awesome the bro
army really is cuz I let's just put
those fits operas come on you can't eat
right now hey there we go alright let's
do this together browsing show how
awesome the bro army really is stay
awesome rest I know you will caramel
activate
you